welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios what if episode 4 what if doctor
strange lost his heart instead of his
hands and what if we all lost our minds
with this tragic horror of an episode
unafraid to sentence its hero to bleak
consequences my favorite episode of the
series yet and not just because it had
like 20 mephisto's in it if you could
even call them that but because this
episode was filled with beautiful
imagery and concepts that are
fascinating to break down but you gotta
do it frame by frame and i'm gonna do
that and point out all the animation
details and easter eggs that you might
have overlooked this video is sponsored
by storyblocks more on them later we
open with the outline of the watcher but
notice how we see more of his body than
usual in fact he's made more and more
appearances with each new episode of the
season as of getting closer and closer
to finally intervening but by the end of
this episode we do actually see his full
flesh before he reverts to his astral
silhouette like a judge who abides by
habeas corpus to render a guilty verdict
in person before returning to his
chambers he says what if the best of
intentions
has very strange consequences
[Music]
yeah that music was michael g aquino's
doctor strange theme which comes back
throughout this episode
where am i
the ancient one warned us if we save
christine we destroy the world
[Music]
benedict cumberbatch and rachel mcadams
returned to voice steven strange and
christine palmer you
stunning i'm only going for dessert you
promised me creme brulee yes in this
universe strange and christine are in an
active romantic relationship instead of
the platonic but still flirty exes they
were in the film she coaches him on a
speech no no stop i'm already asleep
come on cut the preamble
just get straight to the heart of it
choice words for a doctor who spends
this episode trying to awaken his dead
loved one the heart that he lost now in
the 2016 film strange invited christine
to a speaking engagement i'm talking
tonight at a neurological society there
come with me
another speaking engagement so romantic
you should love coming to those things
with me but here the event seems like a
different one that's a celebration in
strange's honor we need to celebrate
this we are you performed a radical
hemispherectomy it could be another
variance or maybe one of those prior
dates when strange and christine were
still together also we should point out
that a hemispherectomy is where half the
brain is removed or disconnected from
its other half in order to treat
seizures and epilepsy which is quite
similar to the way the ancient one
splits the halves of doctor strange's
identity in mind now the wreck is caused
by slightly different conditions like
here strange tries to pass a semi truck
and nearly collides head-on with a car
swerves back into his lane but then gets
rear-ended in the film he passes a car
and collides with it while distracted
but still the wreck itself goes down
exactly the same way frame by frame even
spinning into a pole and then flipping
on its front end into a fence before
teetering down into the water strange
cries over christine while framed in
this broken glass of the back windshield
you think about it this whole series
depicts the multiverse as shards of
broken glass and at the end of this
episode after strange has allowed his
universe to melt away he is trapped
inside a condensed prism of shards
crying once more alone so this shot here
in the crashed car foreshadows strange's
tragic destiny strange ends up in
camartage but this version of strange
has not had his hands damaged which in
the films was his unhealable wound with
that trimble even persisting all the way
through avengers in game but you'll
notice not in the trailer for spider-man
no way home got a theory for that keep
that in mind for later but still having
his hands allows steven strange to
surpass the mastery of his film version
and this guy never having a constant
reminder of his arrogant mistake to
ground him in that guilt instead he
feels like the universe stole something
from him strange discovers the eye of
agamotto cradle of the temporal
singularity discovered by cagliostro
manipulation and alteration of timelines
yes the temporal singularity of course
referring to the time stone the word
singularity coming from wong's recap and
infinity war of the stones being the
singularities from the big bang as in
the film strange uses the time stone to
unwind and rewind the bites of an apple
and he is caught in the act by wong and
the ancient one with benedict wong until
the swinton returning tinkering with
time can weaken the very fabric of the
universe we protect reality we don't
threaten it but in the film mordo joined
wong in admonishing strange but mordo
was mysteriously absent from this
episode they didn't even bring in a
guest voice actor to try to emulate
chill tell echo for like they normally
do for actors they can't get back in
there not sure why but without this
scolding conscience it does unleash
strange to go further with a sorcery
than he would otherwise as in the film
the ancient one dies and strange
bargains with dormammu and becomes a
sorcerer supreme but now he uses the
time stone to return to the night of
christine's death now compared to the
time travel logic of loki in end game
doctor strange's time stone magic seems
limited to within his timeline like he
doesn't create branch timelines so much
as he relives history within his
timeline by reversing time and creating
time loops definitely seems more limited
in scope compared to the more
technological quantum approach to time
travel used by kang the tva and the
avengers who when they alter time create
branch timelines this could be why the
tva showed us the infinity stones from
their point of view as powerless outside
of their home timelines but since we
stay within doctor strange's timeline
here this time stone is infinitely
powerful and strange creates a new loop
point that begins with christine at the
car similar to how he used a time loop
to torture dormammu but here strange
creates this groundhog day scenario to
essentially torture himself really which
is ironic because dormammu was benedict
cumberbatch with his voice and performed
via mocap all this plays out like the
heartbreaking montage and groundhog day
when bill murray tries over and over to
save a dying homeless man the sequence
that always makes me tear up because he
calls him pop and dad he goes to the
extent of thinking himself as a doctor
demanding to see the guy's chart the way
doctor strange arrogantly refuses to let
his patient die there's a moment where
strange seats christine in the car on
one loop and the watcher's reflection
appears beside him but notice how
strange blinks almost seeming to sense
him but no matter what in this montage
death on wheels always seems to come for
regina george
i actually theorize that each of these
fateful deaths could have been sent by
strange's future strange supreme form
trying to fix his own mess and force his
past self to move on because notice the
vagrant who randomly shoots in the pizza
shop for no reason that guy's face is
only shown from afar and here in shadow
because that could be the face of that
strange supreme unrecognizable to his
past self here even when strange stands
her up she still dies in a building fire
numerous casualties including the death
of one dr christine palmer surgeon file
photo ready to go all the buildings
still blazing okay actually that
reporter is christine everhart voiced by
leslie bibb the recurring mcu whih
reporter who first appeared in the first
iron man the ancient one appears to him
from a blue portal which compared to the
golden sparkle portals normally used by
sorcerers might indicate a higher form
of magic allowing one to traverse
timelines or dimensions or realms like
the blue portal captain carter and the
tentacle monster went through and the
blue color christine glows when strange
resurrects her at the end of the episode
now the ancient one would still be alive
at this point in the timeline right
because the night of christine's death
the ancient one was still living but the
fact that she uses this blue portal it's
just interesting to note because she is
someone who has seen every part of her
life and every part of her timeline she
seems to have an omniscience to her and
she could be coming to strange through
another realm and she explains her death
is an absolute point in time absolutely
unchangeable unmovable okay so absolute
points a kind of new rule in the mcu's
ever expanding timeline logic that i'm
sure some folks might debate whether or
not applies to the live-action mcu
titles but for now i'm going gonna
assume it does again in in-game and loki
past tragedies could be altered or
subverted but doing so would result in
the creation of a branch timeline
thanos's snap though could not be
prevented could be practically undone by
extracting infinity stones from the past
and using them to snap everyone back in
the present though the world still had
to live with the consequences of some
people living five years more than
others the sudden population change from
snaps that seemed like it could have
been an absolute point that they just
kind of had to work around but now we
are learning that some events are
considered absolute points they are
fixed load-bearing watershed moments
that cannot be erased these could be
anchor points that were placed in the
timeline by whatever version of kang in
order to maintain stability to that
universe's sacred timeline so in this
episode when strange eventually forces
christine's survival he violates the
natural limits of his time stone and he
breaks the absolute point of that
timeline careening the timeline into a
chaotic branch beyond the timeline logic
that his time stone could have any
control over it's like the darkest
timeline that the ancient one warned
bruce banner about in endgame in this
new branch reality without our chief
weapon against the forces of darkness
our world would be overrun
millions will suffer which the ancient
one in this episode echoes this path
only leads to darkness and the end of
this reality the darkness on that
hypothetical branch that she talked
about in endgame could have meant that
the branch would eventually self-prune
by melting away into this cosmic sludge
that we see in this episode a choice
that i really like because for one it
contrasts the dry dusting aesthetic of
infinity war but also evokes the more
dark matter that makes up the borders of
this reality and in the medium of comics
and classic animation the ink that these
characters are literally drawn in but as
we move on from this remember christine
palmer's death is only an absolute point
in this universe not the universe of the
primary mcu because she's still alive in
the primary mcu we're all still fine so
this would suggest that different
universes are structured with different
absolute points that that kang timeline
scribe considered to be unchangeable so
the ancient one attacks strange to keep
him from going further and notice how
her spell explodes in a white impact
blast i love when the show does this
it's really fun to pause at the right
moment like first she does it when she
brings the edges of her runic fans
together and then when it hits strange
it creates this one black line where he
was standing representing how the
ancient one just split his soul in half
so strange thinks he survived it going
to the distant past to the library of
cagliostro before this library was lost
alongside several other ancient
libraries like the burning of the
library of alexandria in this case
cagliostro was an actual real person in
history but in the lore of marvel comics
he was an ancient italian sorcerer and
it was his spells of the book of kai
leostro the spell book in the 2016 film
strange is greeted by obeng voiced by
akamari and he later implies estranged
that he is not himself kagliostro but in
fact in the comics obeng is the possible
real-life name of the actual cagliostro
and notice how he has one blue eye and
one reddish brown eye maybe a clue that
strange is here in a split reality split
between a place where his eyes stay
clear blue and another place where his
eyes go darker and at times red the lost
library of cagliostro is beautiful
inside and out the facade of it has
carvings of winged griffins and then is
flanked by larger sphinxes the sphinx is
the mythological being who pose the
riddle which creature has one voice and
yet becomes four-footed and then
two-footed and three-footed the answer
being man who crawls on all fours as a
baby walks on two feet as an adult and
uses a walking stick in old age which
you could see reflecting strange's
journey as a man in a literal sense
taking multi-limbed forms but also lives
throughout centuries as obang ages into
an old man who cannot stand on his two
feet as he tries to go inside strange
encounters all these protective runes
much like the ones wanda and agatha used
against each other in one division
wizards love runes and oben greets him
sorcerer armani no it's it's strange not
any stranger than any other name in this
world calling back the name word play
that kaiselius had with them in the 2016
film how long have you been at karmatage
mr
doctor
mr doctor it's strange
maybe
who am i to judge inside the library of
cagliostro strange finds the book on
time manipulation this is the same book
of cagliostro from the camera tag
library that we saw in doctor strange it
has the same cover but this would be
hundreds of years earlier before it
ended up in camertash the page he
actually opens up to are the same pages
that kaiselius tore out of the book in
the 2016 film and you can see that same
dark dimension symbol the one that
kaiselius conjures in the church and
appeared on his in the ancient one's
foreheads because the ancient one would
draw power from the dark dimension
that's why she was called a hypocrite
now trust me when i say making video
content is time consuming especially if
you want that content to be really high
quality you know the type of videos that
people fall in love with well
storyblocks saves you time and helps you
make your videos that much more lovable
a storyblocks membership is essential
for any creator again thanks to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
they have a huge library full of 4k and
hd footage after effects and premiere
pro templates music images and sound
effects to bring your stories to life
the assets are royalty free so you can
use your downloaded content anywhere for
commercial and personal use the
unlimited all access plan gives you
unlimited downloads for the over 1
million assets in their library choose a
plan that works for you from their
selection of flexible subscriptions at
scale to give you all the content and
tools you need to focus on creating not
worrying about budget storyblocks also
has this really cool new program the
restock initiative they are hiring
creators from marginalized communities
to create content that is more
reflective of the diverse world that we
live in go to storyblocks.com
new rockstars now or click the link in
the description to check out their plans
and get one for yourself learning that
he has to absorb other entities strange
attempts to absorb the freaking same
interdimensional tentacle monster from
episode one with captain carter now i
speculated then that this could be one
of the elder gods aka the many angled
ones like schuma gorath who is
speculated to appear in doctor strange
the multiverse of madness this is a huge
deal that it came back because other
than the watcher himself this is a first
example of continuity on this series and
since the trailer showed that one image
of captain carter meeting the strange
supreme i think we can expect a later
episode this season to confirm what
exactly this monster is and keep in mind
that we may only be seeing this entity's
bottom half and shang chi promotional
footage seems to be showing some massive
tentacled entity in that movie's final
battle we'll know more after shong chi
comes out but there could be a
connection between these two obang says
mystic beings do not bargain
their powers are not meant for man a
very weird thing to say because uh yeah
dormammu totally did bargain at least
eventually after being worn down unless
you consider that the deal strange made
with dormammu might have not been a deal
in strange's favor but a curse that
dormammu might have benefited from
strange starts smaller this time with an
evil little gnome and then an insect
whom he sends back but takes its cloak
of levitation meaning that this might
have been some alternate variant in
reality that was a sorcerer and you'll
notice that this cloak has a darker
color and golden lining similar to the
flesh of that insect himself he then
absorbs a cosmic six-eyed bird whom he
strips of its feathers and then a dragon
that i guess you could say looks a bit
like the great protector of chongqi that
dragon turns his skin red and gives him
horns making strange look a bit like we
have to admit mephisto because this is
followed by a freaking double-headed
goat like the skull we saw in agatha
harkness's satanic dungeon and then this
laughing humanoid being with a skull
head a cape and with antlers and then a
snarling bat demon now now this episode
never explicitly calls any of these
entities mephisto of course it didn't
but this demonic imagery alone dispels
that stupid myth that people keep
throwing at me that disney will never
put demons in their properties as if
fantasia and hocus pocus never happened
or wandavision with its witches and book
of the damned and by absorbing these
things strange gains enough power to be
able to perceive past reality to the
form of the watcher which is the kind of
reality bending abilities normally
reserved for entities like mephisto but
the fate of his universe is not worth
risking the safety of all others
besides
i doubt he'd listen
hello
who's that so mevisto confirmed well no
of course not not yet technically but
this is the kind of supernatural evil
within strange's consciousness that i
mentioned in my recent video that makes
it at least more likely that doctor
strange and no way home or multiverse of
madness could be influenced by mephisto
and since in that no way home footage
strange's hand is not scarred and does
not tremble i am wondering if that could
be the strange from this reality a
theory i go much more into in our
episode of inside marvel now the next
absorbed demons include this evil elk
that makes strange grow antlers giving
him a silhouette of hella another dragon
who makes strange's face stretch out
into a snout a demon wolf with weirdly a
pierced ear and then a snake that turns
strange into a snake that still has his
hair yikes but then we gotta look at
these flashes of body horror that go by
real fast you gotta go through frame by
frame first they're strange in this
thick boy red hellboy style demon form
who sprouts a second head then strange
made of this yellowy waxy substance then
strange in an insectoid form with
antenna and barbed appendages and then
fascinatingly strange with the facial
texture in the eyes of dorm mamu
including a third eye on his forehead
could throughout this process strange
have at some point absorbed dormammu as
well he transforms into a snarling
fanged strange with rows of glowing eyes
who then turns back into strange's
semi-normal head but his skin cracking
like a paper lantern burning from the
inside meanwhile the time lapse outside
the library shows the lush greenery
wilting away from the cliff side as
hundreds of years have passed so then
strange re-summons that tentacle monster
from the beginning this time slicing off
its limbs and absorbing them into his
flesh ending with this gross neck snap
now it's interesting how the creature's
tentacles still have some life in them
even after they were cut off which could
mean that when those severed parts came
back through the portal with captain
carter in episode one those pieces could
still be dangerous to peggy and the
others of that universe abang reveals
that strange supreme was merely one half
of himself in a split reality and then
we jump back to his other side who has
moved on from christine but strange sees
that this reality is melting into the
inky sludge and the ancient one arrives
to explain what's going on
no whoa wait a minute
yes so this must be a psychic impression
sense through a splinter in reality just
think of me as an echo now you may ask
why is the ancient one ghostly now but
in a more living form when she appeared
strange before well before the ancient
one would have been alive at that point
in strange's time loop in early 2016 and
because she is all knowing she just knew
the implications of what strange was
trying to do then but now she would have
been dead after strange to become the
sorcerer supreme and by psychic
impression and echo it appears that she
has left this sorcery-based carbon copy
of her mind which is now flickering
because her magic is fading in this
dying universe and this echo is trying
to explain strange what she had done i
drew upon the power of the dark
dimension to split the timeline
allowing for two of your possible
timelines to occur in one universe yes
so as the ancient one did in the 2016
film she used magic from the dark
dimension that's why she had the symbol
on her head that's why kaiseles would
call her hypocrite but it's interesting
how the ancient one's words remind us
that timelines and universes are not
synonymous and interchangeable they're
really different structural categories
because branch timelines coexist within
one universe similar to how in loki
branch timelines could snake off of the
sacred timeline but that all of those
existed within the same universe and
that the more branches from that sacred
timeline make that bigger universe less
stable so in the end when it splintered
off into thousands and thousands of
different branches that whole universe
was one of infinite more but i'd love
the audio distortion effect on the
ancient one's words but notice how the
distortion snaps back into clarity right
on the one line when she delivers a key
message if the other strange succeeds in
reversing an absolute point in our
universe you mean saving christine he
cannot save us stephen the resulting
temporal paradox will destroy this
universe so wong hooks up strange with a
protection spell guardian vichanti heavy
duty protection spell oh yes the
vashanti are actually a trio of godlike
entities oshter hogoth and agamoto who
serve as patrons for the sorcerer's
supreme those who sit above and the seal
of the shanti that forms the sanctum
window is referencing these vishanti and
i like how the runes burn into his face
these are actually the same ones that
swarmed the alternate strange in the
cagliostro temple which remember he
could handle one at a time but the swarm
of them collectively was a bit
overwhelming for him which explains why
this strange is able to for most of the
battles stay evenly matched as they talk
to each other strange supreme rages and
you can see for a moment shadows of the
other absorbed entities burst out of him
in fire including a claw and horned
animal skull and he takes him back to
the scene of the crash for a brief shot
you can see the broken windshield glass
refracting the form of good strange
showing how he is from a broken reality
and in this case might be a bit less fit
for battle and then they dual strange
supreme uses the beastly demons inside
him he turns his hand into tentacles to
break through a good strange shield and
then he deploys sand worms and then the
two cloaks of levitation square off but
then good strange's cloak sacrifices
himself
oh you can even hear a pained little
scream when he tears apart strange
supreme distracts him with his orb of
light and then creeps up behind him to
drag him into a shadow realm might even
be using strange's ability to see the
watcher into distracting him that might
just be the watcher but no it's actually
his shadow self and then he uses the
inky dark matter that people are melting
into to form the memory of christine but
good strange realizes it's an illusion
and strange supreme punches him out of
it shattering like a glass pane you can
see those shards falling with them
another example of how reality even a
small pocket reality like this one takes
the form of a delicate crystal just on
the verge of shattering shockingly
strange supreme defeats him and absorbs
his other self and eye of agimoto turns
red along with those runic rings around
his wrist which would normally of course
glow green but this is no longer
manipulation of time but manipulation of
reality like the red reality stone but
also like wando maximoff's chaos magic
red meaning less orderly and more
insidious strange's final form is a
freak includes tattered wings tentacles
horns hooved feet and multiple eyes just
plopped randomly all over the face now
again the name fisto never gets spoken
this episode but the demonic nature of
strangest transformation speaks for
itself like notice when he says her name
his voice is accompanied by separate
whispers
and as he leans into christine his extra
eyes all twitch independently of each
other and as his reality's final pieces
crumble apart these other entities
suddenly vacate his body
no
this wasn't supposed to happen because
you could argue these mystic entities
might have come out on top hijacking
this sorcerer's supreme to destroy his
own universe so when obang said mystic
entities don't bargain the fact that one
of those could have been dormammu could
mean that dormammu won that battle after
all and that all these entities down to
that little gnome might have been
victorious here strange begs to watch
her for help i read about you sensed
your presence you're a god you can undo
this i'm not a god and neither are you
if strange had read about uatu the
watcher that would imply there might
have been others in this universe
powerful enough to have witnessed or
sensed the watcher's presence in the
past who else in this mcu could be aware
of watchers perhaps kang or he remains
maybe the ancient one maybe even wanda
maximoff who did suddenly see someone
while reading that darkhold in the one
of edition post credits scene but
strange is left tragically alone
clutching christine as she melts away in
his hands similar to peter parker
dusting in tony stark's hands i'm sorry
i am so
so sorry
one life one choice one moment can
destroy the entire universe and as the
episode goes to credits we are just left
with this feeling like some kind of grim
cautionary tale but for whom exactly now
sure you can see this as a lesson about
the dangers of clinging too much to a
lost loved one fixing what cannot be
fixed but the most impactful images of
this episode are the tale of a wizard
who goes too far none of us are
sorcerers with the ability to reverse
time or rewrite reality well uh yet
working on some stuff on the side i
really think this episode just seems
like a taste of the horrors to come as
characters in the marvel world face
multiversal madness especially in the
live action universe that's why i think
it's definitely worth considering this
episode as having actual implications on
titles like no way home and multiverse
of madness because it's the first
episode this season that did not use a
single sound-a-like actor as if this
live-action cast knows the importance of
this story on their character's journeys
and yes it reintroduces that multiversal
monster that seems like it could tie
into multiverse madness or even chongqi
so there was a time when folks were not
sure if marvel's what if was essential
watching but now i think it is clear
this is essential re-watching you can
support new rockstars by checking out
all of our merch options like this what
if shirt that when you get you can write
in a custom shout out that will appear
on our what if after shows get all of
that at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you